so within the overall field of
conservation right now there's been an
increasing focus on ecosystem service in
support of human well-being as opposed
to simply the conservation of
biodiversity and in fact CI has changed
its mission from one of conservation of
biodiversity about three years ago the
the alteration in the mission was to
conserve biodiversity ecosystem services
for its impact on human well-being so
this is a simple graphic of our theory
of change which actually applies across
lots of organizations we take actions
that we hope will affect the health of
ecosystems however you like would like
to define health and you could do it in
a number of different ways just as you
would define human health in a number of
different ways but at least ostensibly
we would take a set of actions that
would conserve maintain or improve
ecosystem health we expect that will
have an impact on ecosystem services
which hence will have an impact on human
well-being again the details of defining
each of those boxes is an interesting
area that we're currently working on in
fact my group is working on and testing
different approaches in Madagascar at
the moment there's an example here for
freshwater but of course it's most
important to look across a set of
ecosystem services not us not at each
service individually because they're not
orthogonal they're not at right angles
to to one another and it's also
important to come up with indicators in
each of the boxes if you like of the
theory of change that's a fairly concise
set many of the the studies that have
talked about indicators for ecosystem
health have come up with this enormous
list you know a hundred different things
that you should measure which in a
policy context actually isn't very
useful for two reasons one it's very
difficult to absorb and secondly because
people will choose the indicator that
they prefer and say well you know but in
in my context I'm doing extremely
well because we can see that the you
know soil nitrogen has increased and and
that's not very useful out of a very
long list of a hundred things on the
other hand if you can come up with five
or six indicators in each box perhaps a
longer list of ecosystem services then
you get a general sense of direction as
opposed to an extremely narrow
evaluation of ecosystem health and again
think of the human health analogy
there's a few indicators that tell
medical doctors where to look but they
don't necessarily tell everything so
every time you have a physical they do
the same five things to start the
physical but then if they need to
explore deeper of course there's lots of
other tests that can be done having that
kind of a metric of whether in fact
we're making progress our actions have
had any impact is quite important in a
conservation context and you would think
that it would be a normal course of
business but in fact it isn't for lots
of reasons which we probably could
discuss for a while it hasn't been the
case that people have consistently
measured conservation effectiveness for
ecosystems services in human well-being
and where while we and others are
working towards that end now it's
actually a pretty interesting area to
try to come up with the measures that
are responsive but not so highly
variable that they become meaningless
nor are they so stable that it doesn't
really make any difference because the
indicators never change it's it and I'll
show you some examples at the end of the
talk on something called the ocean
health index that makes some steps in
this direction in the Hoffman paper we
also looked at what would have happened
the red line is what would have happened
without conservation action so while
there's still a decline you see that in
fact conservation action can make a I
would argue significant difference when
you look across the entire red list data
set in slowing that decline hasn't by
any means halted the decline but there
it is possible
conservation action to slow the loss of
species